- Okay, very good morning to everyone.
Welcome to re:Invent 2025,
and it's our pleasure to welcome you all,
and to our session on accelerating
development and DevSecOps
with Amazon Bedrock and Kiro.
This is a funny thing,
two weeks back we had to kind of quickly
change from Amazon Q to Kiro to give you a
feel about how to use Kiro, and Kiro CLI.
So, we've been chasing a lot of people
to get the things updated.
So, finally we have some good content
to show you on the
latest services as well.
So, I just wanted to
understand the people here,
before we get started
with the introduction.
Can you tell me how many of
you in the room are developers?
Please raise your hands.
Okay.
I see quite a lot of
development community.
Fantastic.
And can you tell us how many of you
hold a title as a leadership,
like technology leaders or managers?
Wow.
It looks like more than 50%, right?
And how many are solution architects?
Okay.
Looks like, like Fabio,
you all have multiple caps.
Fantastic, right?
So, in this session we are gonna show you
how you can accelerate
software development lifecycle
using agents beyond just
code generation, right?
So, that's what we're gonna cover today.
So, my name is Dhana Vadivelan,
I lead the EMEA Partner
Solutions Architecture team
for Strategic Consulting Partners.
I'm based in London.
I'll let my co-speakers
introduce themselves.
- Hello, hi, hi re:Invent.
My name is Fabio Oliveira,
as you can see with this
accent, I'm Brazilian.
I support partners in
the DACH and CE region.
I am located in Munich.
So, I'm part of the Dhana team.
And also I'm here probably
because I built part of the
system we will see later on
in a part of the demo.
So, happy to be here.
Thank you.
- Hi everybody.
My name's Joris Conijn,
I'm the CTO for Xebia Cloud,
and also an AWS ambassador.
And I have something great to show you
as well during this
session, so hang in there.
- Thank you.
So let me give you a bit of story, right?
Why we are here, and how we
actually landed here, right?
So, a year ago we started
getting a lot of questions
from our partner network and
as well as customers, right?
So, "Tell us how to use Bedrock
to solve certain use cases
or certain adoption issues."
Right?
"Tell us how to use MCP.
Tell us how to integrate
with the existing tools,
the data silos."
So, then me and my team,
we took this as a mission.
We started creating quite a
lot of architecture patterns,
design best practices,
and we also went and started
creating some sample codes,
sample applications to show
the art of possible, right?
And then slowly, slowly we start seeing
our partners start adapting this.
And then we saw a trend of
creating a platform
driven approach, right?
By bringing all the different architecture
patterns that we created,
and then we saw some of our partners
fantastically created a
platform-driven approach
to address all the different personas
within the software
development lifecycle, right?
Not just limited to the
developer community.
And that's where it becomes
even more interesting, right?
Then our partners started
creating their own offering,
and offering that through the marketplace.
And some of them are
combined with our customers
and that's how we actually landed here.
So we wanted to share our learnings,
best practices, and experience with you,
and we would love to hear back from you
in terms of how you like to
use it for your organization.
So, at the end of the session,
you will have a clear takeaway in terms of
how to do this transformation
within your organization.
So stay tuned.
We are gonna show a lot of
QR codes for architectures,
sample codes,
and Fabio is gonna show a demo,
and then later Joris is gonna come
and explain about the
Xebia platform as well.
So, in the next 50 or minutes
we are gonna cover this.
We'll start with the
traditional SDLC challenges,
I will quantify with some financial impact
in terms of what we see from the industry.
And then we'll move into why agentic AI
is unavoidable in software
development lifecycle, right?
And why Gartner in the
recent Magic Quadrant says
the integration of agentic AI is very key
across the software development lifecycle.
And then, we will go dive deep into
the platform-driven approach
using various architecture
patterns that we created.
So, Fabio is gonna introduce some of our
virtual stakeholders like, Emily,
Anna,
Adam,
and Chris,
from different personas in
terms of business analyst,
solutions architect, and
developers, and DevSecOps engineer.
And Fabio will also run through
in terms of day in a life scenario.
Obviously, we have a limited time today,
so we are gonna show you
a few demos and use cases,
but we have 20, 21 plus
architecture patterns
are actually published available today.
So we will share the QR code as well.
And finally, Joris is gonna talk about
how Delta Airlines have achieved
this remarkable journey with Xebia,
transforming their SDLC lifecycle.
So with that, let's get started.
So, let's be honest about
where we are today, right?
Most of the development team
spend lots of time in terms of
repeated task, manual activities,
and missing documentations,
which is resulting in
a productivity drain.
And let me also share stats from
one of the verified
industry analyst report.
78% of the software engineers spending
at least 30% of their time
in terms of doing this
manual repeated task.
So, let me give you an impact
in terms of dollar value, right?
So let's take a team
size of about 250 people,
in a software development team,
if I take an average
salary of about 107,000
in dollar per annum,
the financial impact we are looking at
is about 8 million in
terms of lost productivity.
Another report from Atlassian states that
20% of the development team
lose that time every week
due to inefficiencies,
such as constant contact switching
and technical debt accumulation.
If I do the same math,
it is another 5.4 million in terms of
lost productivity annually, right?
So if I sum it up, it's
about 13.4 million.
It's definitely much bigger
number I'm talking about.
I'll give you an example, right?
So, how many of you here,
your teams are spending at
least more than 40 hours
in a week whenever there is
a tight deadline to release
products or any production issues?
Raise hands.
Yeah, that I see, right?
So this is the burnout crisis, right?
I'm not even counting that fact,
how much is the money spent
or the loss in terms of productivity.
And then the Atlassian
research also states that
if you provide a better
developer experience
and you will see a 30% productivity gain
for your development team.
Which means that we are talking about
the lost opportunity cost, right?
So, these are something which is,
I'm not factoring it, right?
So this is not a sustainable momentum,
that's why the AI agents or agentic AI
is so transformative.
So they don't just make
the old process faster,
they fundamentally change the process
and make it better and cost efficient.
In terms of Gartner Magic
Quadrant for AI Code Assistant,
and this is the one which got
published in September, 2025.
So, Gartner found that AI tools
are transforming everything
from requirements gathering to design,
to testing, to development,
to deployment and operations.
But here is the number that
you should make a note of,
by 2028, 90% of the enterprise
software engineering teams
will start using AI
code assistants, right?
Which is a big jump, 14% in early 2024,
to where we are looking
at in future, right?
Which is 6X increase
just four years, right?
And this is happening,
this transformation is happening whether,
the question is not you're embedding AI
across the SDLC, right?
So this transformation is gonna happen
with or without you.
So the question is,
are you gonna lead this transformation
or are you gonna be
following the competitions?
So, many of you will be thinking,
"Dhana, this is great, right?
How about the real world challenges?"
That is exactly why we are here,
so we wanted to share you the experience
and the challenges that we learned
from our partner network and customers.
Let me bucket this into,
summarize into three categories, right?
The first one is the
toolsets and development.
The development teams
face primary challenges
in terms of fragmented planning
and fragmented development environments.
So, which means it creates
a disconnected toolset
for them to actually collaborate better.
So, therefore it slows them down
in terms of the release cycle, right?
And also creates a barrier from a team
across the team wide collaboration.
So, this is one common challenge
that we learned from our experience.
And then the second one is
the integration and interoperability.
We already said that there
are fragmented environments,
fragmented tools, which is also
creating data silos, right?
So therefore, there is a need
for everyone to actually,
how do you orchestrate this
complex tooling in data, right?
So nobody has the time to do this,
manage this whole
orchestration requirement.
And then the last one is
enterprise-wide security,
observability and scalability.
So again, there are teams who are lacking
in terms of the limited
monitoring and control.
So, which again, poses them a challenge
when they start scaling into production.
So POC is great, now I
need to move forward,
scale it from 10 users to 100s of users,
and 1000s of users, right?
And that's where security
compliance challenges hits.
And of course, it is important
for everyone to start
observing the performance of the agents,
the behavior of the agents.
So, all these things are the
enterprise level challenges
and this is exactly why
AWS developed agentic AI services,
and why it is important to kind of
have a platform-driven approach
to address these challenges.
So, how many of you in the room
are already building agents?
Can you show of hands?
Okay.
And how many of you are deployed
the agents in production?
Okay.
So I see about like 30, 40%,
just in the benefit of bringing
everyone on a common page.
I'll quickly cover a couple of next slides
to give you some foundation,
and then we'll dive deep
into the architecture, right?
So, at AWS we defined
agents, or agentic AI,
as autonomous software systems
that actually leverage to reason,
plan and complete task on
behalf of humans or systems.
I'll give you an example.
I'm sure most of you are using
generative AI today, right?
So generative AI, you give a prompt,
it gives you back the response,
which is one shot interaction.
On the other side, AI agents,
it can actually read your
business requirements,
it can read your user stories, epics,
and it can communicate,
interact with your tools
like Jira or Confluence,
and understand your,
let's say non-functional requirements,
understand your standards
within the organization
when it comes to compliance,
let's say GDPR for instance, right?
And therefore it can
help you to create codes,
it can help you to do the implementation,
do the documentation.
So, all the challenges that
we talked about earlier
in terms of losing 30% of time
due to repeated manual task
and 20% of time lost every
week due to technical debt
and the constant context switching, right?
That is where the agentic AI can help you
avoid those repetitive tasks
and improve the productivity.
So there's a creative
problem solving capabilities,
what exactly transforms
every stages of SDLC.
Now let's quickly look at in
terms of how agentic AI works.
So, we have agents in the middle,
it can be hosted on a AWS
fully managed service,
which is Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
which Fabio is gonna talk about shortly.
Or you can even run agents
on a Amazon ECS platform
where you need to kind of
manage everything, right?
So, it has got four key components.
The first one is the memory,
to retain the context
between all the personas,
between the sessions,
in terms of short term
and long term memory.
And then the second component
is tool integration, right?
So that the agents can
execute task by writing,
issuing all the task in Jira based on
the user stories and epics,
just giving you an example.
And you can even integrate
with your ERP tools
or CRM tools where the data is residing.
And then the third one is
the planning capability
to kind of go through any of
one or more of the options
in terms of reflection,
self critiques, right?
Chain of thoughts.
So that the entire task execution
can be planned properly.
And then the last one is the actions.
The actions can be performed automatically
or with human oversight, right?
So, all these components work together
to actually help agent complete the task.
And now let's look at,
what are the key design best practices
that one should actually consider
when you are actually taking
this agents to production.
Again, this is purely
coming from our learnings
that we've been working
with partners and customers.
There are four key buckets we summarized.
The first one is the
selection of framework, right?
So, it is important to consider
the complexity needs of your project,
of your application that
you are building, right?
And what is the level of modularity
that the framework can offer you,
and the integration capabilities,
and the memory management capabilities.
And then you also need to factor
in things like scalability,
performance things, right?
These things will determine
how best your agentic care
is gonna help you to scale in production.
And then, the second one is
the tools and knowledge base.
Common tools, capabilities,
like, web search,
code interpreter.
And so you need to actually
evaluate those capabilities,
and making sure that provides
you a reliable output
what is needed for your
application, right?
So you need to test that ability
and check the reliability.
And then the third one is
selecting the LLM, right?
So again, the reasoning capabilities
and the execution speed,
all that matters for your application,
and that will also determine what is
the model size and performance,
which will also lead to the
cost of the inferencing.
And then the last one is
the execution technique.
So, there are many options available
within the react, plan
and execute, reflection,
so, you need to decide which one
is better suit for your needs.
And then finally, there are frameworks,
agentic care frameworks,
it comes with this own determined way
of doing workflow automation,
or you may have to do a
custom workflow automation.
So again, you need to
think before you start
using any of the agentic framework.
And finally, make sure you all aligned
the complexity needs of
your project and use cases
to the selection of LLM.
So, AWS meets where you are
in your agentic AI journey.
Our vision is to provide
the best place to build
and deploy most trusted and
performant agents in the world.
So, at AWS, we understand
different organizations
having different needs.
So, therefore we are offering
three distinct approaches here, right?
Just follow along with me.
The first one is for those who are seeking
specialized solutions.
So, we offer the agent power applications.
So, that's the first bucket.
So, within that there are
three services we offer.
One is Amazon Quick Suite.
You might have heard that's
recently launched service,
which is mainly focused on
enterprise productivity
and workflow automation.
So, the good part of Amazon Quick Suite is
it has a inbuilt
connection and integration
with all the tools that I talked about.
So, it is a platform
for no code or low code
for you to quickly create
a workflow automation
by integrating with different tools
and the data available
within your environment
to get a specific task executed.
And then the second one
is the Kiro Agentic IDE.
So, Fabio is gonna dive deep
and show you the console,
and the use case.
We are taking this Kiro
into the next level
of spec-driven development.
So, you just give Kiro
what you wanted to build,
just follow along,
it creates the implementation for you.
And then the last one is the Kiro CLI,
it is a new command line-driven interface
powered by agentic AI from AWS.
And it enables developers
and IT professionals
in terms of helping them to
scan your codes for errors,
do security vulnerabilities,
helps you to fix errors,
and automate the workflows in few seconds.
So, this is one bucket.
And the second bucket is the teams wanting
a kind of control and convenience.
That's where we offer fully-managed Amazon
and Bedrock agents, right?
And that provides the
built-in foundation models,
along with the orchestration capability.
And then the third one is
for organizations who are actually wanting
maximum flexibility.
So, we offer DIY approach.
So, right now there are two SDKs,
agentic AI framework,
Strands, and Nova Act SDK.
So with this you can
actually build your agent.
And for all these options,
one or more options,
you're gonna see here from
our partner Xebia today,
how they are actually using
this to build a platform
and drive at scale.
So for all these things,
you need a platform to kind of scale
from literally zero sessions
to thousands of sessions,
and that's where Amazon
and Bedrock AgentCore
that comes in provides
you capabilities such as
identity and access management,
the gateway capability, observability,
and then the tools that we talked about
in terms of code interpreter,
web browsing capability,
all these things helps you to manage
the agentic development lifecycle.
Right, so, now let's talk
about the architecture, right?
So, as I said,
we started creating the
architectural patterns
for each of the personas
and then slowly we started seeing
there is a need to actually bring
all those architecture personas together
and give them an UI,
and mainly for the non-developers, right?
Who are not using the IDE for example.
So, that's where we
saw there is a need for
building a platform-driven approach.
So I'll quickly walk you
through the solution approach.
Again, this is more to inspire
our customers and partners.
It's not a kind of fully product
or something like that, right?
It's a reference
architecture, best practices,
is published in AWS Samples,
it's open source today.
Anyone can actually clone
it, modify, customize it,
and test it, and use it
for the way you want.
So we have a user persona,
we created a custom UI based
on ReactJS application,
and we used Cognito to manage
the authentication and authorization,
because there is a
role-based access needed.
You don't need to necessarily
give every full rights
to a business analyst,
rather you wanted to restrict
them to a specific task.
So, that's where the role-based
access comes very critical.
And then the backend is,
we created the SDLC agent
using Bedrock Agent,
and which is inbuilt foundation models
with orchestration capabilities.
So we integrated this as an MCP client,
integration and the fast API with our UI.
So now let's move on to the patterns
that I was talking about, right?
So, first we started creating
an architecture design pattern
for the business analysts to help them
do the requirements planning
more efficiently and effectively, right?
So, we created integration
between Confluence and Jira
using MCP server with Bedrock,
and then we connected
that to the MCP client.
So what we realized when
we started doing this,
before we get the next persona to start
taking from what the business
analyst have created.
So it is important to kind
of hold that output, right?
So, that's where we
created a another pattern
called as project knowledge base,
and this gives you a historical
data of every persona,
what they are actually
working on, which project,
what epics, user stories,
they have created,
what are the acceptance criteria,
how you can track the traceability back.
So, all those information
that they generate
from the first architecture pattern
needs to be stored, captured,
and that needs to be reused.
So that's where we use
Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Base
and Amazon S3 Vector.
So, we created an MCP server
and we integrated that
back to the SDLC agent.
And then we started
creating other patterns,
which is the architecture design pattern,
mainly focused on architects.
So here, they will
basically able to create
architecture diagrams using draw.io,
they can create open API specifications.
And then the next persona
is the developer persona.
So here, for Kiro to kind
of have all the information
and create your specification
in the first place.
So again, we are actually integrating that
with the knowledge base so
that it can able to understand
what was the requirements of the project,
and what is the design that
was created by the architect,
and so on and so forth, right?
So then we were able to give
the kind of entire flow,
integrate each one of the stages of SDLC.
And then the testing persona,
again, the same integration
that we did using MCP server.
So in this case we took JMeter
because most of our customers
we saw this as a trend,
and you can actually create
literally any other MCP servers
or the MCP servers that
are available openly,
the open source.
And that's how we created each
one of the other personas.
And the last one is for maintenance,
which again, we used the
publicly available MCP service
from Splunk, PagerDuty,
and we integrated that with Slack
so that your ops engineer gets notified
when there is an anomaly in
your application automatically.
And then it gives you an opportunity
for an ops engineer to
further do RCA analysis.
So that's where Bedrock comes in,
do the RCA analysis by gathering
all the logs from Splunk.
And also, takes all the knowledge bases
that are available in your ITSM tool.
So, in this case we used PagerDuty,
if you have ServiceNow,
again with the MCP,
you can very well connect
with the knowledge base
so that all the previous incidents
and the resolutions that took place.
So, the agent can able to read
and then it can able to suggest
you remediation recommendations, right?
And that's how the whole
workflow starts moving in.
So, that's a QR code
where you can actually
scan and see all the patents.
As I said, we have more
than 20 plus patents
and multiple use cases,
but we have many more coming up, right?
So, make sure you store it, save it,
we will share again once more
at the end of the session.
So, let me quickly summarize
in terms of the architectural benefits.
So, by taking this
platform-driven approach,
it enables you to implement AI
across the software
development lifecycle, right?
And it also provides you an
ability to add, remove tools,
break all those fragmented things
that we talked about
in terms of data silos,
and also by making an UI so you can able
to customize the way how
you want for your users,
for your personas and organization.
And then, we've showed you
the project knowledge base
to hold all the information throughout
the software development lifecycle
so that the information gets passed on.
The agent only refers to the MCP server
for authorized information,
so that's the way how we
are grounding the context
and avoiding the hallucination, right?
So these are some of the problems that
we actually solved in real life.
And then we are letting agents to manage
the complex orchestration here, right?
Because the agent can
identify, based on your need,
which MCP server to choose,
rather than you creating your
own orchestration problems.
And finally, using the guardrails features
that are available we use
to enable the responsible
AI, and other aspects.
So, we are going to come to the demo time,
I know I'm running a bit late,
so for the demo,
we are taking AnyCompanyReads
as a example scenario.
So, currently this company is going
through a traditional SDLC approach,
which is resulting in
the software releases
taking 18 months of time.
And that is mainly due to
challenges that includes
multiple endless requirement meetings
and the changes that happens
to the design documents very often.
And therefore, it gets
outdated before even
the coding begins, right?
And the team could not
avoid the scope creep
and budget overrun.
And in this demo we are gonna show you
how to use the platform-driven approach
so that any company leads can
accelerate all the SDLC stages
and reduce the release cycles
to six to eight months.
Take it away.
Fabio.
- Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Hi, hi re:Invent.
Want to see a demo?
So yeah, I'm joking.
I think you don't have a
choice, I will show anyway.
So, now, well let's go with me,
we'll go through some of the SDLC phases,
and we'll see how our approach actually
is changing the lives of
some of our collaborators.
So then let's come, let's see how it goes.
So, first, let's meet Emily.
So, Emily is our business analyst.
She task is really to go
and to create epics,
from epics create requirements,
to write acceptance criteria.
So, basically, she uses the usual tools
like a knowledge management
system like Confluence or Jira
for the project management
to create the tasks.
So, let's see how
actually agentic AI system
can actually help her with her tasks.
And sometimes, for example,
she's building functional
and non-functional requirements,
she may take like many, many hours,
days sometimes even to create
a non-ambiguous requirements.
So, how agentic AI can actually
make these from a couple of hours
or days to a couple of minutes.
So let's take a look.
So Emily's journey starts in Confluence
as the majority of our
work that normally starts
in the knowledge management system.
So, she writes requirements
in plain English, as usual,
so known requirements,
non-functional and
functional requirements.
And then she can move, for
example, to our platform,
we have here represented all
the different SDLC stages.
So, you have here on the right hand side
you have chat bot where most
of the work will be done.
She can ask, for example,
to the agent to extract the requirements
and help her to build the epics
from extracting from Confluence.
So the system is using our MCP server
to contact, connect and to
extract the information.
And here we have it.
So we have the user authentication epic,
we have the Book Catalog epic,
so all of them with different
requirements inside.
So, you have user
registration, authentication.
For the Book Catalog epic,
we have different features.
So, with the integration
between a Confluence and Jira,
so this information can
be extracted by the agent
and put back on Jira as tasks.
So then,
so you can see e-commerce features,
social features,
it's quite a complex system.
So now what we can do,
or what Emily can do,
is to ask the agent to start
to write acception criteria.
So, based on the
organization best practices,
and here we have it.
So it's using a given-when-then format
for the different epics
for different requirements,
and this can be populated
back now to Jira, as well.
And as Dhana said, so what
is cool about this platform,
we have a central knowledge base
and every persona is contributing
for this knowledge base.
So, everything that we are building now
is populating the central
project knowledge base
that will be shared among
the different personas.
So moving on, now it's time for the team
to get a little bit more technical.
So we will meet Adam.
Adam is our solution architect,
and his task is to combine
the work done by Emily,
the functional requirements,
and is to start to add more information
about the non-functional requirements,
and also follow the organization policies,
best practices, compliance.
So, he needs actually to
digest all this information
and start to build architectural diagrams,
documents, specifications,
contracts between different systems.
So, he uses some of the tools
like diagramming, applications tools,
he needs to go through
sometimes to 100s of documents
and to go and to distill that
as architectural documents.
So let's see how AI-powered
solutions can actually
help him to accelerate his work
that sometimes can take like
a couple of, again weeks,
sometime months, depending
on the complexity
to come up with some of the solutions.
So again, we are back now to our solution
at our AI agentic platform,
and we have built some
shortcuts to help Adam
to go through to some of the tasks.
So for example, here in the
per epic we have a button to,
for example, to generate
a solution diagram,
and this will create the
nice prompt in the shot,
and this will trigger the process
and combining the agentic AI system
with MCP servers to create the diagrams,
we have something like that.
So we have like a diagram,
actually in this case with
a serverless solution,
so it looks legit.
So, we have like S3 buckets, we have CDNs,
we have serverless, we have
Lambdas, we have databases.
Adam can even, for example,
continue the discussion.
This is basically based on
the organization best practice
but can, for example, you start
to change the architecture
for something like containers.
So maybe moving on, part
of Adam role is also
to build like some contracts,
and so using OpenAPI to
build OpenAPI specifications.
So he can go back, select
one of the shortcuts,
and for example, here we have,
so build some of the contracts
for one of the epics.
So, we have like four endpoints,
we have the schemas defined,
the security defined.
So, this is normally JSON
object as you can see,
the OpenAPI specification.
Who likes to write JSON
specifications by hand, isn't it?
So, the agentic system
can help you with that.
And even like highlighting
the human in the loop.
So Adam can actually go
and preview the results
using a tool like Swagger, in this case.
And we can see here we
have get, post, get by ID,
put, delete by ID.
So the different endpoint
for that particular epic,
everything created by the agent,
and now again part of our
central knowledge base
that what helps then to
build up the knowledge
about this single project.
So, moving on, so our next
stop is to talk with Anna.
So Anna is our developer.
So, she's a lead developer
in our Any company,
fictional company.
And she leads her team,
and some of her tasks are to
go collect the requirements,
basically now built by Emily first,
and now all the function in
our functional requirements,
documentation built by Adam,
put together and start to build
the low-level design artifacts
that helps her team to start
to split the development
in development tasks.
So, setting the environment,
setting the CICD pipeline,
creating the documentation.
So, there is a lot of documents
and as you can see the
things start to compound.
So, we have the requirements,
we have the design,
so everything that needs
to be distilled by Anna
to go and to build the software.
So let's see how we can help Anna
with those pain points.
So, Anna and her team,
they are developers,
and we know the best place
to write code is an IDE,
so that's why we will move
to her favorite IDE, Kiro.
Kiro is our agentic AI IDE,
and basically Kiro is MCP compatible,
so we have built MCP
server that connects Kiro
to our central knowledge base.
And because of that,
she can do things like,
she can ask what are
the active projects now
in our knowledge base,
ask details about a single
project like the AnyCompanyReads.
And with that, the system,
we will start to show in the IDE
without leaving the IDE,
information about the different
epics that are available,
the functional and
non-functional requirements.
And when she's ready she can, for example,
even ask to start the work
in one particular epic.
And so, in this case,
we will start to work on
the book catalog epic.
So, because of that integration
between Kiro and our
central knowledge base,
she'll see the information
about the contracts
built by Adam,
the functional,
non-functional requirements,
the signed decisions, entities,
endpoints, as we saw before.
And as soon as Anna is ready,
she can ask, for example, to
Kiro to start to build the,
to use the spec-driven
development approach
to break out the requirements
in requirements design and tasks.
As you can see,
here, we start to help then to,
is split now to or to design
the presentation layer,
the business logic layer,
the data access layer.
So, decision about the
technological stack,
so front end, tables, entities,
so everything will be
part of the project now,
part of the repository.
And after that, she can, for example,
even start to ask to
splitting technical tasks,
and here we have it.
So now the project is empty.
So, Kiro is actually creating tasks
to build the project from scratch.
So, to build the different directories,
set up the Quarkus framework,
it's a Java application, the front end.
So, that basically now,
so you can start to click
on the different tasks
and this will start, now
will provide Kiro access
to the terminal where Kiro will start to
take over and start to run commands
to build the project infrastructure,
the directory,
the different microservices, and so on.
That takes a while,
so, that's why we will move
a little bit forward in time.
Yes, so here we have it.
So, after clicking some
tasks and moving forward,
so we can see Kiro help there
Anna to build different microservices.
So, we have models,
we have repositories in
Java, as I said before,
dtos, repositories,
services,
and even tests
for all the different,
for microservices we have in this epic.
We have deployment scripts,
we have the front end,
and even the CICD pipeline.
So, in this case, we are using GitLab,
so Kiro helped to go into
build the CICD pipeline,
and as soon as we deploy these codes
so we commit these codes to GitLab.
GitLab will run the
first time, the pipeline.
So we have tests, unit
tests, security tests,
we have the setup of the infrastructure,
we have the build of the
different microservices,
and finally the deployment on production.
As you can see, we even
have some security tests,
some security scans on the first stage.
So, that is probably already
making our DevSecOps team smile.
And talking about them,
let's meet our next one,
and our next persona, Chris.
So, Chris is our DevSecOps engineer,
and he has many, many responsibilities.
So, he's responsible for
the security monitoring,
performance, infrastructure management,
compliance and maintenance.
So, many, many responsibilities
and he needs to access
many different platforms.
So, cloud platforms, monitoring tools,
login tools, ticketing systems,
communication tools.
So, there is a lot of overhead,
so cognitive overhead really
with all those different tools.
And time is in production,
time matters a lot.
So, he needs to be 24/7 available,
he needs to have apt incident response,
access to different systems to the data
that helps him to solve his issues.
So, let's see how agentic AI can actually
streamline his workflow
to help him to solve
the issues more efficiently.
So, here we are moving to Kiro CLI,
Kiro CLI is our CLI-based agentic tool.
And with Kiro CLI, he can,
for example, in plain English,
ask the two to check the logs,
see what are the issues
happening in the last seven days,
and categorize them in priority.
So, the plain English
request is translated
in requests to the AWS APIs
using another MCP server.
And this will bring back information
about what are the issues
that are happening.
And here we have it,
so Kiro even classifies
in different priorities,
the different issues,
and with some recommendations.
So, let's move back and take a look.
So, we have for the high priority issues,
we have some issues
with our security token,
and with the refresh
of our security token.
For the medium priority issues,
we have some bad actors that looks like
they are scanning some endpoints.
So, maybe something that
we need to take a look.
And Kiro even provides some
recommendations what to do next.
So, Chris can now even in a proactive way,
you start to plan what will
be the next best actions.
And we have a couple of
different AWS partners
that are actually providing official
MCP service that you can, for example,
even connect Slack with
PageDuty, Splunk, Datadog,
to have all the information
in a single place
so he can, for example, see
what is going on in production,
the issues that are happening right now,
can even check the logs, the metrics,
and based on the knowledge base, again,
the run books, the playbooks,
see what is the best next action
and what is the issues or maybe the risks
related with any of the
remediation actions.
So, with that, Chris is
well prepared to do his job,
and I think that's it.
So, we have done it.
So, I think in 15 or less
minutes we probably went from
from scratch, from zero to a
production-ready application
or deployed network with
security or without capabilities.
So, and I think the
best part of this demo,
it is available as open source.
So, we will share the QR code
at the end, so, stay tuned.
So, then will probably
show now the resource page,
the resource slides,
so you can take a look,
see, learn,
and who knows maybe even
build a product out of it.
But maybe, let's go and take a look
a little bit at what help us to,
with a very small team,
to build this sample
you can see here today.
So, even hearing from
customers and partners,
we understand AWS start to
see that it's very important
to have an infrastructure
that is not on your way,
not to build agentic AI systems.
I think even like in the JSE
in the shareholder ladder
in 2024 said something,
how is speed matters all
the time in all industries.
So I think the things
didn't slow down since then,
even the opposite, so you
cannot have a platform
that will slow down taking
care of the small details
but empowers you to build
complex applications,
complex agentic applications.
And this platform needs to be flexible,
so this will adapt to
your technical stack,
not the other way around.
So, whatever is their choice,
the platform that needs to
support you with your choices,
and needs to be scalable, secure,
provides you with all the telemetry
so you can have an enterprise-grade
application deployed on production.
So, that's why we released
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
AgentCore provides different modules
so we can use them together or separately.
We have, for example, AgentCore Runtime,
that's the place where in our sample
you are running our agents, we
are running our MCP servers.
So, it's a serverless runtime
that provides you all the security.
So basically every agent
or MSC server is running
in a session for security,
it is a related session for
that particular request.
We have the AgentCore Gateway,
that's where you will
expose the different tools
to the agents, so it
provides a semantic search
even to not overload the context
of the agent looking for
tools and to execute,
and also provide some building
tools like AgentCore Browser
that will provide a sandbox environment
for the agents to access the internet,
to access a server-based browser,
who can make actions and execute actions
to the outside world.
Or even like a code interpreter
that will provide also
a sandbox environment
where it can write code,
execute the code and receive the outcome.
So, to have like a more
predictive data-driven outcome.
You have like Identicore Identity
to secure the end-to-end conversation
between the user, from
the user to the agent,
agents to your tool, for your MCP,
for example, base tools,
and from the MCP to the outside world.
AgentCore Memory for your session memory,
for your long-term memory.
So, to have a place to store, for example,
in our case information
about the preferences,
the project,
so to have a more longterm memory
even to share between different agents.
And finally, AgentCore Observability.
So, to have information
about the telemetry,
what's going on,
how many tokens were consumed
by the different agents.
So, to have a open telemetry
agent based information
so you can guide the
optimization of your system.
And now, I think I will leave the stage.
My colleague, Joris,
that'll go to our customer success story.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- So Xebia is a global
technology firm founded in 2001,
and we're active in over 16 countries,
and our experts help organizations
through software engineering,
cloud, data and AI,
DevOps and agile transformation.
We work with some of the
world's leading enterprises
from top global banks and major airlines,
and retail and healthcare.
As an AWS premier tier partner,
we've built deep experience
over than a decade.
Our team of 750 specialists
hold 19 competencies
and have done 20 map
migrations in the recent years.
So, let's talk about Delta.
Delta Airlines is
operating in a high volume,
safety critical environment
where reliability,
speed and innovation directly impacts
customer experience
and operational excellence.
Sorry.
We've been tasked to reduce error rates
and improve productivity.
We took an approach
that took generative AI
and transformed the traditional
software development lifecycle
into a generative AI one,
with the goal to bring more
efficiency to the personas.
So, what were the challenges
and business impact?
Pre-development and architectural hurdles,
unclear requirements,
inconsistent criteria,
slow prioritization,
paired with a pattern
of inconsistent security
and non-functional requirements,
creating foundational issues
leading into longer cycle times.
Development and testing bottlenecks,
code duplication,
inconsistent reviews,
weak test coverage,
and poor data quality delivers,
the delivery impact and impacts quality
leading into quality variance.
Pipeline and operational friction,
problematic CICD workflows,
alert fatigue,
delayed troubleshooting,
and limited cost visibility
leading into higher
operational overhead and cost.
To solve these challenges,
we developed a platform
and this platform is called Xebia ACE.
We've combined Xebia's
value realization framework
with AWS best practices,
and with this system in
place we have have an ability
to identify and track measurable benefits.
This enables us to drive development,
the development lifecycle transformation
through various personas.
We've identified 50,
more than 50 use cases and
50% are already in production,
and we have a 100% adoption rate.
With this platform in place,
we observed a 40% increase of productivity
and a 30% reduction in error rates.
The time spent on writing specifications
went from days to minutes,
cycle times and manual effort were reduced
and additional cost was avoided.
So, our AI-powered software development
lifecycle acceleration platform
is an end-to-end solution
that leverages the generative
AI and AWS services
to streamline automatically
the critical stages of a
software development process.
ACE will have a holistic
view from the start
till the end of your
software development profile.
It takes the unstructured requirements
into a production-ready artifact,
significantly reducing development time,
and improve quality consistency
across your enterprise software projects.
An example of these
artifacts is, for example,
a C4 architectural diagram,
which is being generated by our platform,
and that will power your
architectural decisions.
With all these rich structures in place,
we can feed solutions like Kiro,
like you just saw in Fabio's demo.
We also have a 15-day trial
available for this program,
and we will show a QR code at the end,
so, please stay there for that.
So quickly, let's go
over the main components,
because I'm also seeing that
I'm running a little bit late.
So, various personas, just
like the other product
that can use the system.
Solution ACE is fully
running on AgentCore,
so that powers the heart of our solution.
We use Bedrock and the Bedrock
models to do the inference,
and we use a knowledge base
powered by OpenSearch to
do vectorized searching.
We have a data layer
that will actually feed
these vector stores so
that the agents are powered
and make sure that they can do their job.
And we connect various
tools like Jira, Confluence,
through MCP servers to
actually create epics, stories,
Confluence pages or Figma designs.
Oh.
Sorry about that.
The whole solution was
designed to be serverless,
secure and scalable.
And this, this is just the beginning.
I'm exciting for the future
what will bring for this platform.
Thanks.
- Thank you Joris.
So like Xebia, we have other partners
built the platform driven
approach, like Integra Tech,
Zero&One, IBM, Cognizant, and PWC.
You can see lot more partners
are actually going to adopt this,
and they're actually
innovating quite fast, right?
What you just heard from.
There are a couple of more case studies
we have in the limited time.
I'm gonna kind of run
through very, very fast.
But the slides and the entire session
will be available in YouTube later,
so you could able to see them as well.
Iskaan is a Dubai-based
building management company.
They had challenges,
the traditional challenges in SDLC
and scattered requirements.
Integra Tech, one of our AWS
premier consulting partner,
they built a platform-driven
approach called as iCODE,
and using that they could able to address,
solve some of those use cases as well.
Specifically, the time
consumed in terms of designs,
reviews,
they were taking quite a lot of time
in terms of fixing
issues in the production
because there is no automated way
to understand what is happening.
So this is one.
And the other case study is from Zero&One.
Zero&One is another AWS
premier consulting partner.
So, they created a
offering to help Zonevoice,
is a customer based out
of, again, Middle East,
and they also serve customers across Asia,
Africa, and Europe.
So, that challenges some of
the business critical applications,
were actually hosted on Java 8 application
having outdated critical libraries.
So again, Zero&One,
they created a AI-powered SDLC integration
and with GitHub automation
that actually accelerated
the modernization part.
So, call to action.
So, these are some of the resources
we have actually put together for you
in terms of reimagining the
operating model from an SDLC.
100s of use cases that
we actually envisioned
that you could actually
create and implement
based on the value that
delivers to the customers.
And then the last one is the accelerators,
which is the samples and
reference architecture
that you have seen.
So, these are the QR codes
for each one of them.
And if you wanted to get your organization
on a learning path with agentic AI,
so we have courses which are created
for partners and customers as well.
So, log into AWS Skill Builder,
and then you would able to scan this.
Once you scan the QR code,
it takes you to the
whole learning session,
like level 100, 200, 300, right?
And as Joris was telling,
they're offering 15-days
trial for their SDLC platform,
so please feel free to contact them
and they will arrange an
access to the platform.
So, if you wanted to talk to us,
we are gonna be staying there
for 15 minutes in the corner,
feel free to come and reach us out,
or you can also fill in the form
so that some of our solutions architect
will get in touch with you,
in case if you wanted to work and help you
with some of the customer
acceleration challenges.
With that, thank you so much
for attending this session,
and thank you so much for our co-speakers.
I hope you enjoyed the session,
and have a great rest of the re:Invent
Thank you so much.